朱老師要用一堂課的時間
讓你了解支撐跟壓力多重要
支撐壓力在哪
就很了解
第二天是紅黑上來
他就有支撐
這邊第一買的人也在賣
所以就你爆出大力
上一次的支撐
是下一次可能是壓力
你又懂趨勢
又知道支撐壓力
你就會買也會賣
抓到這些位置
你可以做到賣在高點
買在低點
我們要連哪些點
來化支撐壓力
你有兩個低點就會連上成些線
那下次回來這邊就是支撐
我怎麼知道誰長得多
那就是上面壓力遠一點的
如果到了這個壓力的附近
出現了一個
大概八九成就要下來
技術分析的兩個精華就在這
朱老師
有粉絲還以為我們的
標股在線等已經完結偏了
還早了
因為還早你講的
還早
因為你太久沒來啦
對啊可能在連假都去玩對不對
對
因為放大價嘛大家也要休息了
大家也要休息
股票市場的交易量也變少了
對
但是我們的每個人的體重都變多了
那是放假正後勤
對啊可是連假期間因為每股不平靜
所以台灣也蠻多新聞的
都是有關於政黨
然後一旦政黨就會出現這種字眼
就會說哪裡是一個支撐
哪裡是一個壓力
例如說你看這一個新聞
周選支撐與壓力區
落在1萬2千4到1萬2千7
從技術面觀察台股上週反彈
已經來到季線下源壓力區
然後這邊說問能重返
支撐約160點附近
然後壓力為166點附近
說真的 看完等於沒款
什麼支撐什麼壓力
在地圖分析裡面
其實最重要有兩個東西
一個叫趨勢
一個就是支撐壓力
如果你能夠把趨勢看懂
又知道支撐壓力
你就會知道它跌到哪裡
長到哪裡
所以支撐壓力
是一個很重要的課題
所以我們一定要了解
因為我們之前的課程
有時候我們在看江坡圖
我們在講當充那一集
沒錯
其實朱老師也有提到說
這個已經跌破他的支撐
可是我沒有教
所以很多的網友跟觀眾就說
什麼是資產壓力你們還沒有交
我們今天就來討論
好我們先開個場
就是李台單秀的標虎在線等
大家等很久真的在線等了好幾週
因為我們最近連假的關係
所以我們跟朱老師這邊
就讓他小小的休息一下
因為朱老師也是要休息的
他到處講課
有時候咳嗽大家都很心疼
那大家會記得嗎
我們在之前的課堂裡面
沒有告訴大家 跌破支撐
或者突破壓力是個很重要的訊號
可是我們都還沒有正式的來講
什麼是支撐 什麼是壓力
所以今天這堂課千萬聽好來囉
朱老師要用一堂課的時間
徹底的讓你瞭解
到底支撐跟壓力有多重要
好 所以朱老師
怎麼一回來就一張
我們來看這張圖
開始投圖啊 好美喔
趙環你看看
這個人推了這麼大一塊石頭
這個會被他壓下去呢
還是他可以把石頭推上去
他就有兩個結果嘛
要就上去要就下來
我是一個樂觀派
他當然要把他推上去
那推上去當然這個力量
要比石頭下來的力量還要大
他才能夠推得上去
沒錯
如果他的力量比他小
他就會掉下來了
被碾壁
被石頭追的話
好那我們來看一下
骨架下跌跌不下去
一張圖我們秒懂什麼是支撐
我們常常會發現股價跌了三天
跌了四天 為什麼他不跌了
愛跌不跌卡在一個地方
一般來說如果股價不跌就是有支撐
為什麼會有支撐一定有理由
所以基本上他出現支撐有兩個狀況
第一個因為跌深了
因為跌得太多 所以有人會來減便宜了
一看跌這麼多就來買了
就有買盤了
那第二個就是
他跌下來上面有人在做空啊
因為有人在賣股票不然怎麼會跌
那做空的人呢他獲利回補了
他要把他的空欄補回來
有一個買盤進來
加上跌升的買盤
所以這個地方就容易有支撐
所以他有支撐
那反轉向上就該處就有支撐
如果他撐住了又往上走
那就表示這個石頭跌不下去了
這個地方有人在接著他
然後往上推
這就跟我們過完林匠會變胖嘛
因為我們一直在吃東西啊
一直在回補
所以就有支撐
那壓力呢
那我們看壓力就剛好相反
壓力就是股價上漲漲不上去了
也就是我們在尤其大家都喜歡做多
為什麼做到某一個位置它就會跌
它就下不來了
對 它就再漲不動
如果各位去複習一下前面
我們其實有講
在做多有跟大家講
為什麼要三天四天不要去追
不要追高了
就是因為股價漲多
有人獲利在賣了
你在這個位置前面下面買的人在賣
第二個還有一個解套的賣壓
也就是在前面有人高檔被套牢了
那你現在股價又上來了
那他就想趕快解套
所以他就會有兩個壓力出來
一個是獲利的賣壓
一個是解套的賣壓
那這時候如果你推的人
也就是我們買盤了
如果你買盤沒有辦法再繼續加油的話
可能他就看不住
這個就好像賣壓
對 他撐不住
他就撐不住
那就會下來
那就代表這個地方有壓力
那我們回到技術分析上
我們用一張圖來看資深壓力在哪
就很了解了
我們來看這個地方
是不是我們有講過K線橫盤
K線橫盤現在突破了
那突破以後它跌下來
那跌的是不是跌得很深
已經跌了兩個多禮拜了
怎麼會到這個地方它就漲了
對啊
所以我們不疊了呢
有可能像老師教過KD啦
KD都可以觀察一下
都可以觀察
因為我們的支撐壓力有非常多的地方
那我們今天也會教大家去看
那幾個地方會有支撐
或者有壓力
第一個當然前面這邊一個盤整
對不對
所以這邊盤整的第一點會有支撐
第二個這是季線
季線支撐大量K線支撐
那這邊有一個很大的量
對 這裡有個大量
所以這裡有個第一點在這裡是支撐
那我們到這裡你怎麼知道它會有支撐
因為你看第二天就知道了
第二天一個紅K上去
第二天是紅K上來它就有支撐
所以它就往上跑了
所以我們要看第二天才知道表態了
對 第二天確認
第一天是遇到支撐位置
第二天我們看這個位置
果然有撐 有沒有支撐
就來第二天確認
確認了它就有撐 它就上來了
上來我們剛剛有講連漲三天
這是不是在高檔了
有人在賣了
而且各位不要忘了
這邊買的人跌下來他是被套牢
被套牢囉
所以你現在上來他也想賣
在這裡買的人也想賣
所以這個地方就出現大量
然後也一樣看第二天
第二天黑黑的他就下來了
也是一個確認之類
這個地方下來了
請問最上面這天買的人
這麼多人買是不是也被套牢了
那現在又來了
對
他又可以解套了
是趕快賣啊
他解套這邊就趕快賣
這邊低買的人也在賣
所以你爆出大量
那爆了大量是黑K
黑K就表示今天賣壓很重
過不了那個壓力區
所以你看後面他就下來了
所以我們碰到支撐
你就要注意
他如果有人買他就會上來
碰到壓力如果第二天跌他就會下來
這很重要耶
因為代表說這邊其實是一個相對比較低的狀態
可能賣不動了
反而要注意賣點
這邊就要注意賣點對不對
所以你知道資深壓力
尤其是你獲利的人
你就知道你該要走了
因為這邊有人在賣
所以他也可以看出一個多空趨勢
沒錯
好
那我們來看一下
但是我們先了解一下
資深壓力它是一體的兩面
一線兩面
同一條線
不同的一面
沒錯
我們一個簡單的定義
如果你的股價在這條線的下面
那他就是壓力
就是趙華湘講的
你現在體重50
無三就是壓力
太棒了我要永遠再無四
你的體重在下面
可是不要有一天衝過了
我永不回補
有一天你一衝過了他就變支撐了
那就是我了
我維持了70公斤很久
過一個節就變75了
現在70變成支撐了
對不對
就是你過了
你把這個壓力這個邊是個壓
剛才我們講嘛
這裡頭這裡沒過
對
這裡沒過啊
現在是不是過了
對
那這次一過了以後
經過很長時間
他又回來了
對
這時候你過的這個就變成支撐了
那有沒有支撐到這邊
他這裡是紅的
所以他就會有支撐
那反過來這裡
我們在驗證
漲一天漲兩天漲三天
爆出大量
有壓力囉
這裡有上銘線了
有人在賣了
那這個應該就是所謂貨利的賣壓
因為這個吉拉嘛
第二天有很高
這個貨利賣壓全部跑出來
第二天黑K他就會回來
回來這裡有紅K有支撐
大概是碰到月線
所以軍線可能也要看一下
軍線也是支撐
那這個跌破囉
這邊是不是跌破
那我們講趨勢現在頭頭滴滴滴
所以這裡你是空頭走勢
這是空頭
空頭下跌就找支撐
上漲就找壓力
我們不停地找他的支撐在哪裡
可能剛剛老師有提到
例如搞不好第一個是軸線
第二次越線越線
再來又是計線
軍線都有
我們到了這裡就會發現
為什麼不跌了
這裡為什麼不跌
原來這個地方有支撐
這裡有個大量紅K
這裡有支撐
上去了這裡為什麼又不漲了
因為這邊跌破了
它又變壓力
上一次的支撐是下一次可能是壓力
對
所以支撐壓力它就是在一線
就同一條線
是
如果支撐壓力是絕對的
股票就沒得完
對
壓力永遠不過
支撐永遠不過
還是要看股價的表態
沒錯
然後它如果跌破了那個支撐線
它可能還會再往下看
對
可是如果上漲
它這個支撐就變壓力了
對 就會變壓力
所以就像多空一直在轉換
對
所以支撐壓力也一直在轉換
如果我們把它看得很熟了
對我操作有什麼幫助
那當然我們來看一下
我們為什麼要知道這些支撐壓力
因為你知道了支撐壓力
對我們操作來說有很多的功能
第一個你就可以決定要不要進
像我們剛才如果多頭回到這個月線
結果它有支撐
你就可以決定進了
如果它在支撐的地方
真的撐住就可以進了
如果月線疊破你就不要進了
對不對
所以你可以當作你的進出的一個
重要的參考
這個資深不能跌破
只要它不跌破我就買
所以你可以當作一個進出
賣也是一樣嘛
我們剛剛有講你拉到高點了
結果這個壓力出來了
把我的均線跌破了
我比如說五日均線跌破我就賣嘛
所以你可以當作你是否進出
第二個就是停損跟停力
停損是比較簡單
因為我們進場的類跟紅
可以大概都有大量
那大量跌破是不是就變壓力了
就被套牢了嘛
所以我趕快跑掉了
把他跑掉
但是停歷了就更重要
我們說做股票會賣嘛
可是你知道要賣在哪裡
什麼時候要出場
這是最難
對
而且還有一個很重要
我們的選股跟這個很有關係
我們大家都知道
你買的股票是不是希望他漲多一點
對啊
可不可以只漲三天
那你怎麼知道這個股票漲得多
還是那個股票漲得多
當然一開始要先研究老師
告訴我們的軍線有沒有多牌
KT有沒有黃金交叉
那是進場的條件
他長多多我還真老實還沒交
如果我兩支股票條件都一樣
其實多頭軍線多牌
那我兩支股票只能買一支
那當然要買那支長得多的
我怎麼知道誰長得多
那就是上面壓力遠一點的
壓力越遠空間越大
因為你上漲都沒壓
他不就一直漲
一直漲到有壓的地方
這樣子你就知道資深壓力很重要了
對不對
如果你買一個股票明天就碰季線
那你怎麼會怎麼買
那就做很短了
因為你明天就碰到壓了
所以你買一個股票
如果能夠漲5天才碰壓的
那你大概都有10幾% 20%了
所以資深壓力跟你的停力非常有關係
空間很有依據
對
這個就在資深壓力
當然還有預測走勢多空
比如說多頭回檔
我們前面第一點叫支撐
那跌破就不是多頭
如果沒有跌破我還可以繼續做多
所以我們懂得自身壓力
你就可以在這個走視圖裡面
去發揮它的功能
你可以掌握進出
你可以知道會長到哪裡
然後你的停損怎麼射
然後還有你還可以知道
趨勢改的沒有
這些自身壓力
三項技能囉
決定要怎麼進出囉
停損停立的依據
甚至多空走勢的判斷
水方重要 好
那怎麼叫做多空走是判斷的改變
我們在多跟空這個趨勢裡面
有兩個很重要的特性
大家一定要知道
如果你是做多投股票的
多投趨勢的
支撐不可以跌破
那支撐比如說你多投回檔
會碰到越洩
會碰到前面低點
這些不要跌破
一跌破表示你的多投轉弱
因為支撐撐不住
空頭就注意壓力
我們空頭反彈
反彈不要把壓力突破
那可能就上去喔
尤其是重要的壓力
所以我們在講技術分析的時候
空頭一彈上月線比較小心
它就很容易打底了
它很容易做第二支前
所以等於做空的人也要注意囉
對 因為我們知道
多頭趨勢是一個上漲的趨勢
那既然上漲 支撐都撐不住
當然就轉弱
那空頭應該一直疊嘛
就要變強了
我們會把壓力都突破
不怕壓力了咧
那就表示多方強了
吃太多了
多方強了
那我們怎麼知道真有資深真有壓力
對 這個就最重要了
也就是說我們多頭走到靠近壓力的地方
因為你會知道那邊有壓力
我們等一下就講有幾個地方有壓
那你怎麼知道那裡會有壓
K線就會表現
對 這就是K線
當日的K線
告訴你有沒有接近K線的功能就在這
因為K線是在看轉折的
有壓就會轉嘛
沒壓就不會轉嘛
如果到了這個壓力的附近
出現了一個黑K
那你心裡就要準備了
大概八九成就要下來
因為你碰到壓了
沒錯
對不對
碰到我們就先尊敬他
先看折對不對
你就看他K線今天變盤線了
常上影線了
對不對
那你就注意一下明天
所以第二天你就要小心了
第二天如果開低走低
那就表示要回來
那我們剛剛有講
你經常已經知道
到這個壓力是我的獲利空間
那現在到了
你已經賺了15% 20%了
那結果今天是黑的
你是不是準備明天要
把它賣了算
你要停利了嗎
對啊
你就要停利了
不要跟他渡過
那如果今天是紅的
那明天還有機會
可能會把壓力過
就續報囉
對你就繼續報
所以到了這身壓力
你就去看
然後當天還有價量
我們剛剛講預壓
如果冒出一個大量
那表示有人在賣
女壓爆亮不好
你賺錢你都想賣
解套的賣賺錢的人也賣
這樣子做好準備
明天他要是不長你就賣
抓到這些位置
你可以很漂亮
你可以做到賣在高點買在低點
因為支撐這邊是低點
所以老師可以幫我們舉一個
用例子來看
我們來看一下
前面一直都在盤著
所以這你是一個支撐的位置
現在回來了
你是不是看到紅K
表示這個地方有支撐
紅K又上了月線
他又跑在月線上了
這個地方上漲回檔
所以你就可以準備進場了
而且剛好他在支撐
還真的就上去了
而且月線也把你撐住了
你前面的支撐他是紅K
所以你到了這你就看K線
K線是紅K
所以只要他一漲他就上來
各位再體會一下
一天兩天三天
所以老師是說像這一根K線K棒
只要只是確認他在支撐上
對 遇到支撐了
第二天就告訴你
紅K向上表拍了
你就可以來了
你就可以進場
因為趨勢是多
所以等到第二天來
趨勢是多
最重要你現在趨勢是多
那我們現在再來看
這個地方有爆了一個量
然後就疊了對不對
那這你是不是就形成壓力
那我現在又來了
我現在大量紅K
那第二天是不是要過
第二天是黑的糟糕
沒辦法過 過不去
他遇到壓力出黑K了
出黑K他就容易下來
那下來這個紅K是大量
所以這裡有支撐
這個支撐不能跌破
所以這邊都還沒跌破
可是到這邊慘了
就完了
所以各位想
第一個你的大量紅K跌破了
第二個我剛剛講了
月線不要跌破
你的月線又跌破
月線是這條桃紅色的線
也跌破了
那這你頭頭低 這個叫趨勢
完了 空頭走勢來了
對
所以我們看到前面的壓就要注意
你如果是黑K 它就會下來
你前面有
這個是回檔嘛
這個就不是囉
跌破這個支撐就有點空頭走勢了
而且將來的話
這也會變成他的壓力線
這變均線就變壓
這個也變壓
那是你準備做空的
你彈上來
如果過不了壓
那我就可以空了
如果你過壓就轉強了
那我就不做了
所以他多空判斷就這麼一條線的
所以支撐壓力本來就是很重要
可是老師你要教我們畫
我們要連哪些點來畫支撐壓力
這個最難了
我們講幾個位置
好像聽懂了但是不會畫
我去上你的課也是這樣
好像覺得聽懂了
後來不是發考卷大家畫嗎
不會畫
我們先看拉底的地方有支撐壓力
你先知道
第一個有大量K線的地方
大量K線是指
大量K線
比如說多頭是不是大量紅K就要攻了
大量的紅K出現
這個紅K的低點不要跌破
因為這個低點是支撐
是
這樣不要跌破
那我們有時候在操作
這個大量的紅K當作支撐的低點
這個低點不要
其實各位用理解的方式也很簡單
這個紅K跌破這些就被套牢了
那套牢請問上來是不是要解套
是
它就變壓了
你都很想賣的意思
沒錯
所以這個不能跌破
這是一個支撐點
那往上走
你看到新的大量
那個低點就不要跌破
你就可以一直往上移
那同樣的如果黑K下跌是大量
我們剛才那張圖的第二個頭
就是大量黑K
那這個高點不要被突破
因為這個高點是壓力
對
所以我們第一個
如果你在走市中看到大量的K線
那個我們叫做關鍵的K線
好,就是帶大量的那一根K線
紅K就化低點
黑K就化高點
它就是壓
它就是壓力
紅K在買牌比較強
黑K在那邊賣壓重
所以這地方反彈上來
這裡就會有壓力
就有壓力
我們拿一個圖來看一下
比較清楚
來看看
各位看這個紅K是不是很大量
沒錯,特別的大量
因為對某個彈枕突破
對,彈枕突破的紅K
所以過了大量結果就出現黑K了
那黑K火一來是不是就變就有壓力了
那這個紅K不能破啊
因為當時會認為他是一個支撐的來源嘛
對當時是這麼想的
所以你一疊破支撐糟糕了
這些人全部被套牢
所以他就很容易就容易殺
所以老師你的意思是
即使他是一個大量紅K
他還是支撐很容易有可能會被破
我們隨時要觀察
不要就有萬里無雲了
對有大量的紅K你就守著低點不要破
一破就表示轉弱了
那你當然就要趕快賣囉
你不賣後面
好大一段
好來我沒有看了
真有一個大量的石變盤線
這個低點不要破
它過了
紅K上去了
就上來了
那上來以後碰到了季線
這季線是壓碼
所以看到黑K疊就下來了
第二天疊就會下來
因為季線如果他在季線上他是個支撐
季線下季線就變壓力囉
他就變壓力了
同樣的如果你季線一疊破
他就繼續疊
一樣這邊是疊破月線
又疊破大量K線
你看重要的支撐全部都疊破了
本來你是很強的多頭
所以這個也告訴我們說
看起來這一根好像會在往上
事實上確定
但是不能疊破
如果你要守就是這一根不要疊破
比如說你在這買嘛
所以這個叫做停損點
你不能點破
所以停損很重要
你守了很久
還是沒有辦法賺到錢
可是你還是要承認
否則你就被套牢了
承認真的是
投資上面的重要一點
要認錯啦
做錯了嘛
我做了結果他停損
我們就守
好像看懂了
再舉一個例子考考看好了
大家觀眾也被考考看
看不看得出來資深壓力在哪裡
我們盡量去找大量的地方
這根量很大吧
很大
對不對
那它是黑的
所以你這上面就變壓力
哦
它是大量的黑K
所以你在這買
你就是我剛剛講
你做多要看壓力
我在這裡買壓力就在這
所以你大概賺不到錢
這麼大的量
而且你這個紅黑量比它小
那你第二天又是黑的
糟糕
它就過不去
所以你就趕快走
如果你買你就趕快離開
這時候你只有小賠
所以這個大量的黑黑上面就是壓
ok
好 那這邊又有出現大量
對不對 這裡有大量有大量
那這個大量一跌破
跌破就轉成空頭了
這個地方是支撐
本來是支撐的
支撐上來了嘛 對不對
從這邊上去
然後這個地方有支撐
它又上來了
那這裡就沒有了
就沒有支撐
對 跌破了
對 沒有支撐
這個低點跌破就滴滴滴了
那這邊就頭頭頭頭頭頭滴滴
所以這個變空
所以這個叫空頭的反彈
那反彈我們剛剛講
一碰到壓
就有個月線下彎是他的壓力
有個月線 然後出現黑的囉
是不是壓力出來了
那你就可以空了
反而做空的人遇到月線下
就像這種壓力區
他往下走就可以空他
就是說我們做空不要突破壓力
他沒有突破再跌就表示還很弱
還是可以繼續
它就繼續下來
好
所以我們去
圖上你就去抓
這個地方是壓
這個地方是撐
因為它上來了嘛
這個就撐
這個沒有破
那這個地方破了就
沒有了
這個
就往下
整個趨勢就改
但這邊有點像盤整區
怎麼畫咧
盤頭
盤頭區對不對
頭部在盤整
這是我們前面有講過
這叫盤整
是
頭頭低沒有底底低嘛
所以叫盤整
盤整區
等到底底底破就變空
所以以後面就做空
那這邊的線我們老師也幫我們畫畫看
第二個我們有一個位置很重要的支撐壓力
就叫盤整區
盤整區怎麼畫呢
盤整區就是你盤整區
剛才我們這張圖也有
照華講這是盤整區
對 很像盤整區喔
對 這是盤整區
所以盤整區疊破
你在上來就變壓力
這邊的盤整區就壓力
所以這個壓力過不了
你就可以做空
好 所以盤整區也是一體的兩面
如果盤整突破了
那漲多了就會回檔
這個盤整就變支撐
如果他突破回檔的時候
回到原本的地方
這個支撐
他要撐住
多頭就要撐住
而且這個地方支撐會很強
因為盤整很久了嗎
對 就是一個盤整區
很多人在這買
不是一天
大概兩三個禮拜
相反的如果往下跌破
你上來這個就要投
那就變壓力了
因為有很多人在這套用
不是一天
所以在這裡我們就加強一個觀念
支撐壓力是有強弱之分的
我們知道剛才
均有壓壓
均有五均十均
二十均壓力比較重
五均比較弱
因為二十均累積了太多人了
他一個月的成本在這裡
那我們這個也是一樣
盤整區的支撐壓力就很強
所以有個股票回到盤整區
大概你就要注意
也可能不太容易跌下去
是
對
就是剛剛講
續機的能量其實很強
比較大
所以坐頭
這個地方要是頭部量越來越大
以後的壓力就越大
以後壓力
還有一種走勢
也很適合來畫支撐壓力
還有一個支撐壓力
是很重要的
這叫切線
多頭你把低點連起來
這個叫上層切線
你有兩個低點就會連上層切線
那下次回來這邊就是支撐
那上層切線也有叫趨勢線
因為你是多嘛
所以這條線是往上
應該斜斜往上
對 它是往上
斜斜往上
所以它有支撐
那如果你是空頭
我們講空頭KK上面是壓嘛
這邊是壓嘛
你把兩個高點連起來
這個叫下降切線
那下次你反彈到這
這你就有壓
就壓力
你就要特別注意
如果這個地方怎麼注意
就是有黑K嘛
你碰到壓力有黑K就繼續點
就繼續點
這適合做空
這適合做多
回來這你有稱紅K你就做多
我們把這個用一張圖表示一下
你就很清楚囉
這張圖我們來看一下
這也是不應該盤整區
對盤整區剛剛有交囉
對不對
住住住住住住住住住
高點沒過
這個低點沒破
他就在這邊盤整
盤整區你把這條線延長
這是不是突破了
突破回來
你又碰到盤整區了
所以這裡有支撐
你盤整區突破就變支撐
所以這裡為什麼容易撐
我們看第一個盤整區的支撐
比較強
第二個月線的支撐
又第二強來了
第三個這裡有兩個低點
我畫了一條上升切線
這是上升切線的支撐
哇這個地方有三個支撐
同一個位置有三個支撐
當然很強
就很多人在幫你撐
ok
那你看到長紅就知道
哇都撐住了
你看這一波就長得很快
對不對
來了這個上升切線還在喔
也現在跌破越線碰到這個了
好跌破越線其實跌破某一種支撐了
對 但是下面有一個支撐
對 也碰到上升切線
碰到上真切線我們去看第二天
第二天就上班
他就上月線
他又漲三天
又來了
他又跌破月線了
又碰到上真切線
他又是紅的
他又來了
他很厲害
這個上真切線還滿厲害的
但是這個上真切線
是你要畫
你自己要畫
因為你打開電腦圖上沒有
你要自己畫
自己學會把低點往上連
你把低點往上連
這樣好了
那我們剛才講的不要忘了
大量的紅K
大量的變盤線不能跌破
跌破就轉弱了
都一樣每個位置都去看一下
大量的K線上升切線
盤整區這些都是有支撐有壓力
那在這邊它跌破越線
又跌破上升曲線那就完完了
我剛剛講好幾個支撐都跌破
還有趨勢改了
投投低投投低
變空投走勢了
你趨勢改了
這邊是投投高啊
對不對
這邊投投低
所以現在變空了
最後連季線都跌破了
哇
所以做空啊
完全空投走勢
反而去做空就可以增強
我們做空啊
我們多空都可以做
對
好
所以我們再來總複習對不對
有一個買賣訊號的三要件
剛剛其實過程中都有開箱
剛才過程中都有講嘛
我們知道這裡有支撐
所以做多回來
如果撐住了就可以買了
確認多空多頭做多
空頭做空
寒冷你就做區間
所以寒冷不要做也沒關係
你不做也沒關係
確認20日均線有沒有上升
月線上升可能重要
如果你做多的話
做多做空確認股價的漲跌
做多股價要上漲
那我們剛剛講碰到資深你還不能做
要看第二天
第二天要有紅的上來
要這樣確認就可以做
那做空要下跌的黑K
你反彈到月線了
結果黑K下來了
那你就可以做空
所以先把趨勢確認
然後再確認支撐壓力的K線表現
也趨勢確認你才知道你要做多還做空
我知道他是多我要做多
那做多做哪你做再支撐
現在不要做反囉
你不要再壓力就要去做多空
遇到壓力應該是做空
過不了壓力區就繼續空囉
但如果站上支撐
它沒有跌破支撐就繼續多囉
這很重要的
這很重要
那你又會看多空
又知道支撐壓力
我剛剛有講
那個技術分析的兩個精華就在這裡
你又懂趨勢
又知道支撐壓力
你就會買也會賣
因為你做多在支撐做嘛
那什麼時候賣
壓力賣
而且老師剛剛有講
如果你獲利空間想大
就選壓力遠一點的
就賺得很多這樣子
不要頭上馬上就碰到
馬上就碰到
動一下就碰到天花板了對不對
所以天花板越高越好
所以我們有時候做長線
就要去看州的支撐壓力
記得 日線跟州線是一樣的
我們也拿一張線圖來看
我們買賣訊號怎麼挑
就從支撐壓力來看
我們先看
這個地方是一個盤整
盤整現在突破了對不對
所以這個地方
有一個支撐突破囉
支撐突破 所以也可以做
然後回來了 回來之後這裡有個季線
季線的支撐紅K嘛 你看是不是有個紅K
是一個紅K
你又可以做 做到哪裡做到這裡有壓
壓力過不了你就賣嘛
過得了就多賺一點
這樣ok
賣完了 趨勢不要忘了喔
這裡變盤整了
因為他沒有過
他沒有過前高
但是也沒有再往下跌
就是一個平衡的
也是低點又沒有跌破嘛
所以他在盤整
盤整突破了 又是一個進場的位置
這邊也是盤整突破
進場以後
因為也是開始爆亮
連續漲了三四天
這個叫回檔
突破的就是支撐
這裡有兩個支撐
我們剛剛有講
盤整的支撐
月線的支撐
所以這裡又開始漲
所以這裡又是一個進場位置
所以我們多頭在進場位置
就是找支撐的地方
不破還有趨勢不要改
趨勢沒有變
又是支撐 你就可以買了
這樣子就可以做到
好像感覺上可以來實戰一下了
可以啦 就是因為我們在前面
教大家多頭回後買上漲
那個回後要買上漲
那個上漲就是確認
就是一個確認
確認有支撐 對不對
所以今天聽完了有沒有很了解
其實就同一條線喔
可是你跌破它
它就在上面變成你的壓力喔
你站上它就變成你的支撐喔
所以它是一線兩面喔
那老師剛剛有特別確認
如果你今天要做多的話
你的壓力遠一點
你要做空的話 你支撐遠一點
你的空間才會大
但是如果你有加入我們的精英班的話
現在還有一個好考量來告訴你
剛才看到都是你的眼見為憑
有沒有肉眼可見
朱老師竟然有隱形的壓力支撐
要來教你
這個在我們的精英班不要錯過
那我們今天的理財大安秀
用一堂課的時間
徹底的告訴你
支撐跟壓力非常重要
因為它是你多空趨勢的判斷線
如果你學會的話
那你進出場 停損停立都沒有問題
希望今天的標古在線等
對你有收穫
我們下次再見了
Bye Bye
字幕製作人Zither Harp